>>Roy: So guys, let's answer
this question together.
>>Maybe put some, like, more--
>>Put a piece of tape--
>>So you're going to put
something else to brace the back?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Roy: All right, but what
about bracing this piece?
>>Mark: Because we explicitly teach
process skills through design thinking,
our students are better collaborators,
they are more resourceful,
and they are critical
thinkers and problem solvers.
>>Mark: We are a public school
with a mandated curriculum
and we have standards
that we need to deliver.
Students need to be literate.
They need to know high levels of math,
but the ultimate questions we're going
to be asked by future employers is,
"Can this person work well in a team?
Does this person have the ability to
problem solve and critically think?"
so those are the things that
we can refine and enhance
with a design thinking process.
>>Roy: How you coming over here, guys?
>>Roy: Design thinking was
something that my teaching partner
and I were exposed to a few years ago.
We thought it was fantastic to try and
help our kids frame problem solving.
>>Matthew: That's a great
first question, you guys.
I like that.
>>Matthew: We were looking at, how
do we get them into a small project
that includes design thinking as a theme
where they're going through learning how
to work in a team, learning
how to ask good questions
and dig deeper into the problem.
>>Mark: What's assessed
are process skills.
The students are graded on teamwork.
>>Student: I mean, you
could do it like this.
>>Mark: On managing projects.
>>Roy: This comes down--
>>Matthew: Roy's doing rollercoasters.
I'm doing Invent a Sport.
>>Matthew: We want to start with
broad questions and work our way down.
>>Mark: Through this design thinking
process, we want inquiry, ideation,
prototyping, and then testing.
We start with inquiry.
>>Matthew: Getting started on your
sport, you have to know your audience.
You have to be able to design it
for them versus yourselves, okay?
>>Mia: Would it involved a lot of skill?
>>Mia: We decided we're going to focus
on the third and fourth graders and try
to create a sport for them.
So the first step was creating a
survey to see what they like in a sport
so that we can put it into
the sports that we make.
>>So we got, "What is the most
important thing you value in a sport?"
"Can you list two things you
want to see in a new sport?"
>>Student: Oh, do you prefer a game that
uses animals, like horseback riding?
>>Student: Oh, yeah, yeah.
>>Roy: That survey helps
us to kind of understand it
from someone else's perspective,
not what I like, my idea,
because I'm not the end user here.
Someone else is, so again trying
to help them to develop empathy,
understanding a different
perspective from their own.
>>Matthew: And then they use that
information to make the design happen.
>>Mia: Mr. Brown provided us with, like,
a bin of tools, like
duct tape and string.
>>Student: The string would be used
to tie the balloons to the cups.
>>Mia: We're supposed to implement
the results from the survey and try
to make a sport that the third
and fourth graders would like.
There's a lot of different
things we have to think
about when making that sport.
>>Matthew: You have an idea.
I have an idea.
Let's take those ideas and let's
make a better idea in the end.
>>Roy: In my class, the kids
are in the prototyping phase.
They are working on a design
project for a rollercoaster.
>>Student: Let's keep
on putting them together
until we see how big we want to make it.
>>Student: Just put these
on top of each other.
>>Jaden: A lot of thinking goes
into building all the ideas
that you come up with.
You got to see if you can combine them.
>>Roy: Explain your concept to me.
>>Roy: This will be the first iteration
and then they're going to test.
>>Roy: All right, so let's
test it and see what happens.
>>Roy: Here are the things
that are working great.
Here are the things that
are not working so great--
>>Roy: All right, we ready?
>>Roy: -- and we want to try and now
highlight these things and fix them.
>>Roy: Oh, we fall off right here, yeah?
>>Jaden: One of the biggest
challenges was probably stabilization.
>>Jaden: What Charlie did was,
he made, like, a diagonal cut.
>>Jaden: To have some
support for the rollercoaster,
we took these popsicle sticks that
we've been avoiding this whole time.
We taped them together and
we put them at the bottom
of the coaster and it really works out.
>>Storm: Oh, yeah, I'm just
typing it in right now.
>>Storm: Design thinking can help us
because we can go through the steps
and find out what we're doing right and
wrong and help us solve a big problem.
>>Student: We might be able to,
like, put another tube in there
so that's more, like, rounded.
>>Roy: So you're saying
just put a tube here?
>>Jaden: What you want to do in
life might include design thinking.
If you're trying to figure
out how to do something,
you could probably apply something from
design thinking to accomplish that.
>>Roy: Did we ask the right questions?
Did we get the right information?
Did we go to other groups for feedback?
What can we highlight and fix?
>>Student: Look at right
here, under this.
>>Matthew: They'll know how to use
these skills and they'll implement
and apply those skills to
bigger and better things.
>>Roy: My hope is that they are
internalizing enough of the process
that they feel empowered to find
problems and solve problems.